new this morning a long time metro
police officer is in the hospital
suffering from a mystery disease that's
taken her ability not only to move but
also to speak that's right Officer
Shanice Bell is now at the Mayo Clinic
in Arizona 8 news now reporter Lauren
negretti joining us live in The Newsroom
right now with her story Lauren good
morning to you good morning officer Bell
has been a Metro officer for eight years
she's just 30 years old a single mom to
a young girl who is not even two yet and
since the end of March she's been in and
out of hospitals I spoke to her aunt and
a personal friend as well as a fellow
officer to learn more about who she is
and their fundraising efforts
Sergeant noticed she was learning words
she was walking sideways Shanice Bell's
Aunt Avion Sims says the family took
Bell to the ER at Centennial hospital in
March twice before a month-long stay at
UMC in April after countless tests she
was moved to the Mayo Clinic they still
haven't pinpointed exactly what was
wrong or what happened the only thing
they know is that her brain is swollen
last week she regained limited speech
asking for her baby Skye her whole
motivation right now is getting home to
Sky Sims described her niece as strong
healthy outgoing and an avid traveler
and I told her the other day I said
you're going to be good you're going to
get back to the gym she said
um go to the gym I said that's right
Belle's mom has been traveling back and
forth from Arizona fellow officer and
friend unique dureau started a GoFundMe
she's great at what she does Doro is a
six-year officer she sought Bell's
advice a couple of months before
starting the police academy you know met
her I was like oh she's she's amazing
she's so strong and I really just like
thanked her for her time and her
knowledge that she gave me then we
became friends after that she and Belle
work within Metro's African-American
recruitment Council oh I want the
community if whenever she gets out of
this
to take the time to actually walk up to
her you know say hello to be respectful
towards her and you know know that she's
an amazing person
it was weeks before anyone realized how
sick Belle was as it's just her and her
daughter at home now the family is
encouraged with some progress with bell
speaking a little bit more every day
reporting from The Newsroom Lauren
negretti 8 News Now